it's a new week and that means it's time
for new releases and this week you're
traveling a new Bourdeaux which from now
on you can refer to as New Orleans
because we're playing mafia 3 your
Lincoln clay an orphan and Vietnam War
vet focused on building a new crime
organization to confront the Italian mob
apparently you're really into struggle
you'll move about the open world looking
for opportunities to make quick cash or
work your way up in the mob ladder you
can go in run and gun but this game also
has cover and stealth mechanics so feel
free to get sneaky don't forget to
interrogate enemies that you've taken
down before feeding them to the Gators
and you start working for the mob on the
7th it would be downright silly of me to
not mention one of my favorite surprise
games of last year vermin tide is making
its way to console this week think left
for dead in every way but with rat dudes
instead of zombies it's loads of fun and
it will remind you of your fondest
memories of left 4 dead like yelling at
that person who made a noise and set off
a horde of enemies your way there's even
special infected and health kits with
limited inventory it's pretty similar
but you and three year buddies stab
shoot and blast your way through
hundreds of skaven and the successful
end of a match results in a dice roll
for some hot new loot worth a shot if
you are left for dead fan stomp out
those vermin on the fourth
origami is a stealth game in which you
play as an undead assassin with the
power to control the shadows you can
create those shadows to become invisible
and then teleport to any shadows while
you hunt down your targets you can
choose to kill everyone in sight or be a
stealthy shadow ninja that's your call
and increase your techniques over time
to add to your deadly bag skills become
the assassin on the fourth not really
into Forza but you do like to race well
world rally championships is hitting ps4
xbox one and pc this week because it's
the official video game of the 2016 FIA
world rally championship it's featuring
cars and rallies from the 2016 season
it's pretty much self-explanatory you
drive fast on the seventh finally Paper
Mario color splash comes in to shake it
up it's a plot that could never be
expected yes Princess Peach has been
kidnapped you'll also find similarities
to sticker star with turn-based combat
where you're looking for stars at the
end of courses where's the color part
you ask well your hammer smashes color
on that lifeless world which levels up
your hammer and gives you more
opportunities to find cards the battle
system is all about playing cards from
your deck and you get cards from
exploring the world or you can buy them
in the shops either way you're going to
go through a lot of cards you can delve
into the fifth installment of the paper
mario series on the 7th and that's all i
have for you this week do you remember
that release dates are based on retailer
listings and I'll see you again next
week